under sludgy gray skies they move amidst
the wrecked buildings waiting for an
attack they think could come at any
moment
the front line is increasingly moody
it's tense with expectation
the soldiers know this conflict is
shifting and they fear the might of
vladimir putin's army is massing not far
away in the areas held by russian-backed
separatists
the kremlin calls the soldiers a
peacekeeping force but the commander
here tells me that is just another
deception
territory
controlling
the war has been grinding on for eight
brutal and unforgiving years
this memorial to a ukrainian mortar unit
sits desolate in the shadow of a smashed
up school
all along these front lines there are
reminders that death is never far away
and the abandoned buildings tell their
own stories of lives changed forever by
this conflict
we've just heard the sound of fire in
the background we've come into this
school uh for cover
this has been abandoned in the fighting
all of this town here we're close to
donetsk airport
now the soldiers we're with they are
worried about what has happened with
vladimir putin's recognition of the
breakaway regions they think that
this may really be the eve now
of a big invasion into this area by
russian forces
it is hard to convey just how close the
villages are to the front lines this one
is regularly hit by artillery but
amazingly people still live here they
are the old and the infirm
people like eighty-three-year-old
stephan ivner who have nowhere else to
go
come on
so
ukraine is a country under psychological
and physical siege
the soldiers here say the sanctions will
not be enough to deter further russian
aggression
and they know they may soon have to
fight to defend these positions
as the kremlin redraws the map of
eastern europe
alex rossi sky news near donetsk